[موسيقى]
هناك في ثلاث مباريات اساسيه لحن اطلاقا
مع دول الخليفه الاولى مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه هي انشاء مركز لا تسريع الابتكار
بالاقتصاد السعودي
ويقوم على جمع القطاع العام والقطاع الخاص
لتحديد العوائق المانعه على الابتكار
واقرار السياسات اللي بتسمح لازاله هذه
العوامل
المبادره الثانيه مع دوله الامارات
القادمه
[موسيقى]
فبالقطاع التجاري والتجاره الدوليه كمان
مع دوله الامارات
وتبني
التكنولوجيات اللي بتسمح برقمنت المستندات
التجاريه وغير من الاجراءات اللي بتسهل
التبادل التجاري بلحظه عم نشوف صعود
الغرائز الحمائيه بالعالم
[موسيقى]
انها تقريبا 60 شخصيه
عم بتشارك من الدول العربيه
وعنابينهم كمان حوالي 60 شركه عربيه عم
بتشارك هذه السنه
بنفس الوقت الملفت انه هيدا اعلى سنه
عندنا نسبه نساء قاد نساء مشتركين تقريبا
ربع المشتركين من المنطقه هل من النساء
وهي سابقه بتاريخ المنتدى الاقتصاد العالم